could you please take your seats we're
going to go ahead now with our panel
discussion
guys and it's my great pleasure to turn
the microphone over to Pat and I'm not
going to say much I'm simply going to
follow the same routine I have some
index cards that have come already so if
those of you who have questions and
would like to submit them in that format
I will permit the panelists to speak to
one another to question one another
first try to be as compact as possible
in your comments to one another
I will then read some of the questions
that I've gotten or conflate I mean some
of the questions overlap a bit and then
we will turn it to those of you who have
other thoughts have arisen in the time
being
you have questions for one another okay
I think one of the questions that I
heard repeated a number of times the
question about D biasing natural
language processing the the the the
question of language was sort of passed
over and and so all the examples
involved English but were based in
languages in which gender is less
prominent than in a language like French
or German or even German or or Spanish
and and I wonder if you have anything to
say about don't you need to D by us
human language first and I think there
was another observation about the degree
to which researchers like Lear aboard
its key talks about example the word for
bridge in French is masculine and the
word for bridge in German is feminine
and people respond to the same bridge
with very different adjectives how how
do you how do you build that in so maybe
we can start with that question yes I
think that so that's a really
interesting question we were actually
just having with Shafi a very
interesting discussion during the break
about those lines similar questions
arising in hebrew and also in chinese so
the short answer is that's so that's
that is an active area that we're
currently actively working on i don't
really have a lot of answers right now
it's the reason why we really focused on
english first is that that's where a lot
of the mostly commonly used embedding
public inviting algorithms are trained
on and they even with in english there's
already a lot of interesting variation
for example if you look at different
different types and the different corpus
of data
use particles or silica pedia or news
articles from New York Times versus from
The Wall Street Journal or from BBC
right so there's already a lot of really
interesting variation that we're trying
to know Geographic and cultural
variation we're like the key some parts
just within English so that's basically
mostly occupying us for now we we are
working with some collaborators to look
at this for for other languages
especially languages as the question
mentioned that has gender they're
already much more filled into the into
the words in the language itself
comfortable with your habits one other
thing just as you were talking I was
wondering about in and sort of changing
gender signifiers with like you know
what would be how is a key keeping up
with like the the emergence over the
last decade just in English again of
they them pronouns things of that sort
yes so that itself is also a really
important point
so the initial work has a very strong
limitation and it's basically looking at
basically gender binaries and I think
that's certainly a very a big limitation
of the work we are so there are some
technical challenges just from the
algorithms per sector actually what's
the best way to really quantify because
there's some technical reasons in the
winter days if you find is the good
staple anchors and that's already
challenging as we discussed to do with
binary gender and even more challenging
to do but that's sort of starting
something where
yeah so it just struck me that you've
got I mean I have no idea how you might
go about doing this but just the fact
that we're at a historical moment where
you have an emergent new sort of set of
signifiers I mean probably just messes
everything up but also could provide
some really interesting opportunities
I'm not quite sure how but well I would
feel skeptical about the messing
everything up part because it seems to
me one of the problems we've always had
if we if we start on a certain kind of
project similar to this with a set of
binaries that already reflect a
particular cultural set of assumptions
and then we've got to fix it to add what
is really a bigger picture I mean I
think I always feel like why can't we
ever so fixing it and and expanding
becomes the problem right now I'm not
actually saying that's negative but I'm
just saying it becomes a problem why
can't we begin with the fact that this
is has to be absolutely provisional
right it's gonna be taking on soon just
what we're talking about Latin Nets the
the the changing pronouns for trans
people so that we're not because every
time we represent if we start here we're
gonna have something that is considered
a norm and then everything else is going
to be problematic to that norm and I
would be concerned about doing that and
can I sort of expect because there's a
question that's that is along the same
lines language is not necessarily binary
but polysemic provisional markers are
not necessarily stable APRA no Meah yeah
markers are not necessarily stable but
prone to innovation and change how do
you account for the fact that you are
not getting or perhaps not getting
stereotypes but normative or hegemonic
ideas as a result of the researchers own
confirmation biases
right so so also a very very good point
a very good question so so there's a
couple of ways that we try to
essentially find orthogonal sources of
information to basically to go beyond
our own confirmation bias so basically
you know from a scientists perspective
okay so we know what are the missions
aqua somes like the most we try to do is
to really refine can we find ourselves
forces of theta right so we tried this a
few different ways one is two of us the
use is large-scale citizen science right
so can we talk okay on our own
confirmation bias commercially try to
get inputs from people and we could be
system science we can actually try to
get data inputs from diverse communities
in diverse groups that's one way we can
try to do to get more sources of
validation so the other one which also
is very much limited is from the using
public data sets like the US Census and
using previous studies all right so they
have their own limitations which is
certainly important to talk about but we
think that optimists were more talking
about issues
Nancy had a question I can't read your
handwriting
I wonder if you could possibly it looks
really interesting so size is not the
only problem here so the first was on
the what the assumptions embedded in the
language and everyone I was really
thinking about your presentation about
the mesh language and that it also seems
that somehow they're not getting it like
the fundamental problem with the notion
of Caucasian and the kakizou terminology
which is that it's scientifically
discredited on other grounds because
when blumenbach came up with that which
most people don't not runo if they're
not like floating around this literature
he chose the caucuses because it had
mount ararat which is where noah's ark
was supposed to have landed and it
seemed like a sort of neutral place not
in the midst of a lot of european
politics at the time to say that white
people and also humanity emerged from
that and opposed to whites / Caucasians
at the center and then the others
generated literally that's the what
terminology used to generated and so
that from the framework of if you have
an out of africa hypothesis for origins
of humanity it's a completely invalid
term and so i don't can't understand why
it would even be allowed to continue it
i get your point which is you're picking
up older literature that's used it but
just like and this is a completely
elusive quest where you asked for like
the flagging of obnoxious racist violent
language whether it's in twitter or in
facebook or whatever
cannot mesh find a way to flag this is a
racist study its use it has the wrong
assumptions behind it versus this is a
study that's using language
appropriately so that was one i'm just
sort of thinking about because that
framing and that terminology is
fundamentally flawed from any kind of
rigorous credible science and so I
always will tell people and if I'm
reviewing articles you cannot use the
word Caucasian or any of the other
permutations let it alone negroid
[ __ ] etc because it's just
completely incompatible with
contemporary scientific knowledge tested
by lots of her people robustly around
the world
so that
so a question of how could you in these
things where you're relying on older
data and older studies is there a way to
make them flag this is bad don't use
this term use that one and so that so
that was that and then the related
question was to to you Harriet also on
the the census data for the 1840
controversy I just think a really
important point about the latitude for
it was basically the further north you
go the more likely blacks are to be
insane had also to do it wasn't that it
was falsified data it was that it was
really lousy data presentation so the
problem was for the 1840 census there
was a long line what both were
transpiring I think yeah but there's
much stronger on the the problems cuz
this is again where I think data
scientists can be really helpful in
understanding how do you structure the
data records to get a better science
because what was happening was for the
1840 census you had all data for a
family on one line of data and there
were all these columns that went on
forever and then there was and then what
happened is a lot they introduced this
term of idiot for a really nice
sympathetic term for people that had
mental problems for white people that
were classified as I could easily be put
in the black column so there are plenty
of white people who were classified as
old and mentally incapable who were put
in lines and then claimed to be black
when obviously there was not a black
population and public health people and
Evelyn knows this very well Shattuck in
particular what he did with the 8 after
that he was brought into the 1850 census
to actually for the first time have
records be by individual within families
to reduce that kind of data error so I
think there's a lesson in here about how
we have systematic data collection I can
reduce these kinds of errors that come
into play but I'd really be curious
Evelyn for your point about how can you
flag bad uses given what you've
discovered yeah
we just if the term the basic terms of
if the basic terms are so completely
invalid anyway what's the quality of the
medicine what's the quality of the
research and should the whole article I
mean we talked earlier about getting rid
of the database is is this something
where we should be flagging this as this
is I'm not saying to actually destroy it
but just like it is this is something
that should be destroyed because it's
working with completely flawed
categories so there's probably many
variations and directions we could go to
the answer to that but I think part of
it is with the National Library of
Medicine they would have to confront and
take a stand on the fact of what these
categories the kind of work these
categories have actually done as people
use them in their research you know so
the National Library medicine not
exactly the most radical institution in
the federal government I don't think
they want to take that stand meanwhile
also that you know all the different
kinds of researchers that are submitting
articles with using Caucasian all the
time some again who's going to say that
this has to stop for this set of reasons
both historical and political and
medical such that it does not provide an
adequate or even reasonable or
scientific quote/unquote scientifically
valid way to characterize white some
white people in America of certain kinds
of descent right so I just think that
nobody wants to take up the question and
so I think it's partly my personal view
is mostly political but I also think
it's it's a technical and structural in
that it would require them to do a kind
of reverse engineering on some of the
pieces that are that are continue to be
pulled along even as they improve the
quote unquote effectiveness of the kind
of searches that they do so I mean you
have to decide to stop doing something I
just and also be what I'm what I wanted
to say this morning was that the fact
that in order for certain
of things to change like this we need a
robust process to hold institutions like
this accountable who are holding on to
data that will be used in medical
situation that affect people's lives but
there is no robust accountability
process so at what point do I as a
citizen right - NLM and say I don't want
to see Cochrane soda on here and that
God knows I don't want to see me grow it
in here anymore I mean they'll say well
gee every one of us thank you for your
letter and we'll take it under
consideration that would be probably the
end of it I could not agree with you
more this is an important issue however
where does it end I'm thinking about the
turn cough question the Pern cough Atlas
was devised by a beautiful Atman bodies
devised by it's not working right okay
anyway I'm the prune cop Atlas a
beautiful atlas of human body device
using some Holocaust survivor is then by
an Austrian Nazi and many people think
we should not use it and we have clung
to it because it was accurate because it
was so beautiful we have not been
willing to give it up and I think that
there is a great deal of research not
just definitions I think that's like the
tip of proverbial iceberg a great deal
of research that forms the basis of our
Canon that was that was I'm conducted on
by abusing subjects very often
african-americans other groups as well
and so where do we Institute where do we
end it you know where do we decide where
something is not acceptable personally I
would love to see us decide that we're
not going to use the research that was
performed on African Americans but what
would our cannon look like in that case
you know even though I would like to see
that happen I'm well aware that it would
completely transform you know our image
of Medicine it would there would be a
cost in other words
so we are part of this on new projects
of the human cell Atlas which is some
international effort very ambitious to
essentially create something like a
Google Maps for the human body right and
I think a lot of the points that you're
racing here are extremely important for
that project and it's not currently
considered for that fabric because the
Liberty the goal there is to create 15
reference if the human genome projects
who creates a reference human genome for
for for humans the human stylist is to
recreate a reference map for individual
cells in your body right for you know
for foreskin for hair for neurons all
the different cell types and I think
would be extremely important for just as
a opportunity for for people here to
where would the samples be derived
exactly so so so okay Youth HeLa for
example are you ready to use HeLa it
would be so they're not using so they're
using a lot of others so sort of example
not from not from Kayla but right now I
don't think there's a comprehensive plan
and a boat map to see what are the South
pipes what are the donors who will be
the donors to give me story sometimes
from
yeah so my question is for James um I
think maybe just because I was tired at
the end of your talk I was having a hard
time following what precisely you were
plotting in this chart where you were
comparing when you were talking about
how the word embeddings across time
change and I'm curious whether any part
of that statistical analysis you drew
you do boxes and lines of where certain
historical events took place but I
didn't know if those historical events
played any role in your analysis other
than you seeing some some change some
more yeah yeah yeah so I sir sorry I
didn't go through that in too much
detail so basically so the high-level
idea is that at every time point we have
by embedding or set of vectors for these
different adjectives and for in
stereotypes and across to 22 different
time points I can compute how similar
they are how correlated these likewise
the covariance that's right the
correlation metric and that's so that
heat map that it that I was trying
basically was just showing the the
similarities across the different times
it's just mean it changes over time so
yeah so it's just showing that there's a
particular a few pretty abrupt time
points where we see especially dramatic
changes in these embeddings of the
diversity of x so that's analysis we did
just currently on the text data and what
we did afterward was to basically Moses
Marcel post hoc kind of patient the see
a vase of water work now at 10 pointed a
few five points when he sees his
lordship's what actually happens in
there was kind of oils that could be
relevant so we didn't actually do it's
it's not a causal analysis because we
did that post hoc but this is showing
you a few events were based on our
cognitions the historian
um there's another question for you
hey this again for doctors you you're
the insights of your studies were very
interesting and useful informant and
informative they were also very
consistent with a large body of
asian-american Studies scholarship so I
was curious to know your relationship to
that scholarship and whether it's useful
to cite those studies in your research
whether the value that it's added to the
kind of big data analysis and
algorithmic data driven work is
primarily one of speed in other words
maybe it takes you less time to do this
work than say a historian who would have
already gone through those newspapers
and looked at the semiological meanings
that are generated around say the Asian
girls from the late 19th century and how
they change at precisely the time points
you also plotted for us yeah so so so so
thank you for asking that question we
certainly think that's would be this is
a tool useful for exploratory analysis
it's now any historian or any social
scientist can basically look at the fine
points and see what are the patterns for
certain for some of the time points
where we were able to actually find
additional analysis from specific
studies for example based on surveys or
population studies that came from those
particular time points so and as you
said so they are consistent was the
results that we showed here so I would
view this as now we can actually fill in
some of the gaps because those
individual studies for example collect
by a series of Princeton serve colleges
were over know that you only did three
time points and other studies also only
focused on a few different time points
so now we actually
what's that stay knock now she gets any
exploratory analysis across multiple
five boys at least in the u.s. so one is
just makes easier to do exploratory
analysis much more quickly is that gonna
set with doing some of the fine points
that were not covered to the previous
surveys here's a question for Evelyn
relating to the slide Evelyn showed on
or makeup of Google workforce I'm
interested if there are results that the
workplace diversity that relates or that
link workforce diversity and product
slash output note not that diverse
workforce is not important in and of
itself so I don't I don't know of any I
think it's a good question I mean so I
think it's interesting Google is one of
the few places that actually started
giving up publishing a diversity report
over the last few years just sort of
basic you know kind of demographic data
about their their workforce they don't
break it down at least not in the in the
publicly released report on different
types of jobs different types of
products platform system that people
might be working on I mean those are all
the kinds of things you'd really want to
know who's actually working on like
Google Translate or some of the search
projects or any of that how diverse are
those specific groups I think they would
probably be a little reticent about
letting us know that and given the small
numbers the percentage of ear of the
diversity for for the entire company but
though they're really really important
because again it means that they're it
probably means that in certain places
the products reflect the fact that some
of the questions people with a different
perspective might ask are not getting
asked as the product as the apps are
getting developed they're just not being
ant they're not asking those questions
and then when they get blowback if
they're released in the public then what
happened why don't we think about that
but
because they're not having those kinds
of conversations or at least they're not
willing to admit that they're having
those kind of conversations there's a
question for Harriet could you please
bring the message home a thousandfold
that low IQ tests that low IQ tests are
strongly correlated to bad prenatal care
and thus interventions must be put in
place with regard to that
excellent point they do indeed folate
Abed and the bad P natal care
unfortunately is sometimes intentional
I'm not saying it always it sometimes is
for a very sad reason studies had shown
that back in 1992 study showed that
african-american women and Hispanic
women were the group least likely to be
advised to stop smoking during the
pregnancies now the group least likely
to be advised to do that are Native
American women also there are a
California survey oh I'm sorry don't my
forget who did it but a California
survey showed that most physicians do
not discuss disparate environmental
toxicity impact with pregnant women who
are black and Hispanic even though
they're well aware that these women are
at most at the highest risk but when
asked why clinicians typically said oh
these are people who have so many
horrific circumstances they have a lot
of survival issues and it just seems
like a burdensome to also tell them not
to eat too much fish during the week to
take there and I'm thinking but they're
at highest risk so how can you not tell
them assignments is like killing you
know unborn children and I'm sympathetic
with you know I am suppose sympathetic
for their desire not to burden their
patients more but I think there's
nothing probably more burdensome than
having a child with a defect that could
have been prevented by good care so
there's a we have a lot of work to do in
terms of prenatal care I think when
people think of that they think of um
drinking and smoking because that's
often what's focused on unfortunately
women of color it's a form of blaming
the victim you know demonize days
demonizing women well you were pregnant
you knew that you were smoking you were
drinking but a lot of a lot of mothers
especially Hispanic
the American mothers are younger than
the norm and they tend to not know that
they're pregnant for two months during
that time they might have already done
social drinking there's also a lot of
among women of all ethnic groups a lot
of misunderstanding about the dangers of
alcohol which we don't completely
understand yet
a lot of women kind of assume that by
their third trimester toward the end the
baby's fully formed and yet that's
exactly the point where the most harm
can be done to a fetus when a woman
drinks so there are a lot of things
going on there that women need to be
better informed of by their physicians
and they're not getting that information
they need and one little grace note I
have to add is that there's a small very
small contingent of actually abusive
prenatal care programs where when North
Carolina when women came to Pinot care
programs as they were told to do by PSAs
and their doctors and it confessed to
drug use the hospital reported them to
authorities and they were arrested and
only a few women we're talking about 40
women that we know of but the word gets
out now women who need Pinochle care are
going to know about this they read about
in the paper and they're afraid to go so
we have a lot of a lot of work to do
here I think you made it
it was extremely striking how this lower
IQ points are related to the the bad
prenatal care and bad advice and so
forth but I guess my question is now
that we could it be that we can think of
these algorithms or these machine
learning tools that make it so
abundantly obvious okay more you know it
makes it so clearly true okay and so as
a tool to get it out in the public's
mind that this is what's happening so
I'm trying to point clear that that this
correlation between Lourdes IQ and
prenatal and bad prenatal care is very
clear so it's clear to you but what I am
saying is that I'm wondering is there
any way to say that our tools or
Google's tools or whatever are could be
useful a good end rather than
reinforcing
something that's like with them that's
going to be accurate and right now we
don't even have accurate advice and data
there's not agreement for example on how
much fish we know that um most of the
fish that women eat especially when
they're subsistence farming are gonna
tainted with mercury we know that what
we don't know is because fish is such an
important food for building the fetal
brain it's the risk from avoiding fish
high quality Procrit meth is that risk
greater than the risk from the mercury
there's a lot of disagreement in the
medical field you know you you're gonna
get we actually will see different
advice from different governmental
agencies for example so so you're saying
even though we know the problem we don't
know where the intervention the right
intervention is case we're not sure the
vet were the best at but I'm not sure
the best advice is you know you have
people giving diametrically different
advice to women all having what looked
like good dad at least to me so there's
no consensus yet okay so we if we don't
have a consensus then you can't build an
algorithm so you know there's work that
has to be done but you know the real
issue here is not bad prenatal care
because there is bad Queen natal care
lacking prenatal care but the real issue
is the need for prenatal care and advice
and not all women are getting it so in
terms of giving good making sure women
I'll get the right prenatal care advice
that I think that should be our focus
the miscreants are are there but I think
there's there are too few to focus the
to focus our energy on which we'll be
focusing our energy on getting the right
message out at first so there you have
it but I think that understanding what
the real risks are is often it's clear
we know that good nutrition is essential
and we also know that many women that
I'm writing about living what people
call them food deserts because they
don't have access to good nutrition
that's economically feasible
I call them food swamps because a lack
of nutrition is often coupled with
potent alcohol rampant cigarette and
tobacco advertising you
putting you mix all that together and of
course you're gonna end up with you know
very bad you know natal outcomes it's
going to happen so there's a lot there
there's a lot to do but you know making
sure the prenatal care women get is
accurate is of course important but it's
also really important to make sure that
all women have access to what they need
then you can tell them to get to eat
well but you have to make sure they're
able to do that
the high-protein slurry you mentioned
earlier as well all right you understand
that we're our machine learning is as a
lot of problems at bay and maybe but
it's also a tool possibly immense value
and the question is how can you embrace
that or advise us how to make it a
better tool rather than just say well
you guys as mathematicians and
scientists
I'm rephrasing you a little bit really
don't get it you can't get it you know
lawmakers and policy makers think it's
where it's at yes so so in in many
respects I was trying to not say that
the scientists aren't getting it but
that some of the policy makers aren't
getting it right so the idea is that a
tool is not the same thing as a solution
right and but that a lot of people in
legal and policy circles think that this
tool is a solution and that's a problem
so it's a matter of sort of as I said to
somebody afterwards sort of like a place
for everything and everything in its
place right and realize you know because
there there is this kind of this kind of
imperialism of metrics right with where
there's this tendency for it to sort of
expand beyond the boundaries of it's
sort of appropriate sphere of authority
so it's in many respects more about sort
of a call to sort of recalibrate right
and rethink through what is the
appropriate relationship between these
worlds of law policy politics democracy
and
you know and expertise machine learning
science algorithms and and in many
respects yet my critique is more on the
the people in sort of my world who sort
of think oh all the messy problems of
politics can be solved by science and
just one other thing I was thinking of
it hurried as you were talking to is to
think about how you know target knows
women are pregnant before their partners
do and you know because and they know
this and they start sending them push
notifications but also how that too is
sort of raced in classed in terms of
like who you know who you know I mean
target has a pretty broad demographic
you know database in terms of who shops
there but I'm wondering if you and you
know is that a place for algorithms in a
sense to sort of supplement you know if
you're not going to have your doctor
telling you don't drink and don't smoke
maybe target will and that could be
useful however and I don't know the
demographics but I do know that target
has very cheap prescription drugs I know
it sort of for me and I'm sure therefore
a lot of people too but you know what
this might sound a little bit far afield
but it puts me in mind of one thing I
have noticed which troubles me on this
emphasis on personal responsibility of
course it's a good thing of course we
want women among other things to take
responsibility for ensuring fetal health
to do everything they can but the
problem comes in when you're telling
exhorting women to take control of
something they have no way of
controlling they have no way of
controlling their exposure to
environmental toxins you know short of
you know deciding how much fish to eat
every week and they may not have control
over that a lot of subsistence fishing I
mentioned my talk that I'm I was told by
a Johns Hopkins researcher that African
Americans don't do subsistence fishing
that's what people who fish in order to
feed their families you know not for
support not to sell but to put food on
the table I said that's a surprise to me
because my father did fishing he would
go out hunting with his friends they had
a boat they would fish they would hunt
and we eat venison whether we wanted it
or not you know but it's something that
we did and when our family did everybody
I knew did and I'd seen it a lot so to
be told by somebody it didn't happen and
then to realize that they actually
thought that because no one had studied
it no one had collated that data so
there was a whole underground you know
effect so anyway the bottom line is that
most exposure though you know the
phthalates the PCBs the heavy metals
they have no way of mediating that and
yet they're held responsible for it so I
think we've really careful smoking up to
a point you know but it's similar this
is also a case where the data can lead
people in different directions so a
toast story many times so I get a call
one day from a researcher at Johns
Hopkins that says we're trying to start
a new program Public Health we're at the
black churches in Baltimore they're
going to give away free fruit at the end
of services right on Sunday and and but
they said but we've looked at some of
the data and the people in East
Baltimore don't eat fruit and I said
have you seen the fruit in East Oakland
these little stores corner stores of
fruit is horrible-looking in it's a
wicked expensive but that the assumption
made from all the data that the data was
correct
black people were not buying fruit in
East Baltimore but it's not because they
didn't like fruit or wanted fruit or saw
the value of fruit it was this other
issue but that could not be seen through
that so I think it's something back to
something Dorothy said this morning
about and and I think it's a kind of I
wanted to speak to what you said about
the scientists getting it but the
politicians are responsible for policy
things I still think that but my
assessment is the racism in the medical
system is deep and pervasive and you
have to start there and assume that if
someone calls you with this comment like
like
a question like is it true based on our
data it's true that like people don't
need fruit and you just say yes and you
have to question that because it makes
no sense right I mean if you think of
most people like fruit I mean but if you
don't think black people are the same
kind of people and the person who told
you that probably Congressional on their
cultural competence exactly cultural
exam is not to be tempered by cultural
humility you know you've got to know
what you don't know and that doesn't
happen all for that that's what I need
the presumption of difference is so deep
that that kind of assertion made sense
to the science and I'm saying it's got
to get to a point when it doesn't make
sense
no I think it's about challenging
certain presumptions and assumptions and
that those have to be challenged all the
time if we take seriously that the whole
system is riven with a certain kind of
racial bias we've run out of time thank
you all so much
[Applause]